we're rolling this out announcing a new
screening program for lung cancer the
Prime Minister out in Nottingham today
but still locked in a standoff with some
health unions Rishi sunak also hinted he
may overrule pay recommendations for
junior doctors if he deems them too high
people need to recognize the economic
context we're in and I'm going to make
the decisions that are the right ones
for the country that's not always easy
people may not like that but those are
the right things for everybody that we
get a grip of inflation and that means
the government not excessively borrowing
too much money and being responsible
with public sector pay settlements also
out on the wards labor adopting an
altogether blunder tone they're
definitely the worst hospital I've ever
been in the shadow Health secretary
attacking the government for a lack of
investment but less clear on the vexed
issue of pay I want to see the
independent pay review body process back
up and running with the full confidence
of everyone involved the real risk to
the NHS Now isn't just that staff walk
out for another five days of strike
action but they walk out of the NHS
altogether from strikes and Staffing to
hospital spending the NHS and the
governments are facing challenges in the
short term and the long in the months
ahead further walkouts by doctors May
frustrate the prime minister's promise
to curb waiting lists but there's also
the risk of pay and conditions causing
more health workers to leave a worrying
Prospect for a service already short on
staff
analysis by the charity the king's fund
has found the UK has three practicing
doctors per 1000 people while Germany
and Denmark both have around four and a
half on nurses the UK figure is also low
at 8.5 per 1000 people compared to 12 in
Germany and 10 in Denmark
reports author says this alongside a
lack of capital investment means the UK
is lagging behind on treatable health
conditions It's a combination of not
enough funding and poor planning the
budget for the NHS has been increasing
but by nowhere near enough if you wanted
this rapid growth of doctors and nurses
but the second thing is how we've
organized workforce planning in this
country simply hasn't been good enough
it was split along lots of different
National bodies no one was really
accountable
Rishi sunak will try to address this
when he unveils a long-term Workforce
plan later this week
that won't help with many immediate NHS
issues though political problems focused
onto a Health Service already under
pressure
Sky News in Westminster